the ps4 pro is bringing a shiny new 4k  HDR look to video games next month but  it might end up costing you a little  more I'm Tony and this is your high res  gamespot news update existing ps4 games  like uncharted 4 and infamous first  light are getting 4k HDR patches to  bring their visuals up to what the pro  can do sony has said that it will not  charge for any of its patches but some  third-party titles may charge for the  visual update in an interview with  Japanese site game impress watch Sony  executive masakazu Ito said that this  will be up to the publishers costs will  vary meaning that some updates will be  free but others may not 4k resolution  and HDR are the main selling points of  the ps4 pro if that sounds good to you  you can pick up the upgraded console on  November 10th for 400 bucks for tons  more ps4 pro coverage including in-depth  specs and interviews head over to  gamespot and to keep up with all the  latest playstation news you already in  the right place